[Music]
the number of crimes in our community
continues to rise so homeowners across
las vegas are trying to protect
themselves maybe now more than ever orco
mana shows us how this has led to a
business boom for a local security
company
i wanted that extra layer of security
heidi harris is worried about crime in
her community metro police data shows
there have been 112 murders in las vegas
as of october 1st 2021 compared to 67
through the same time last year that's a
67 percent increase somebody breaking
into your house or somebody you know
hurting you on the street that kind of
steps or at a gas pump or anything else
that's that's scary harris has motion
sensor lights at her las vegas home but
she recently stepped up safety measures
with the security screens i sleep well
at night knowing that i have these boss
security screens these screens are made
up of stainless steel mesh so i can hit
this with a hammer
but it'll still stay intact and it'll
only leave a few minor dents try to kick
down
this door
bob security screen ceo james kerr says
over the past year his product sales
have tripled 80 percent of our clients
are coming to us because something's
been going on in their neighborhood not
just once but multiple times he's also
seeing surveillance cameras and home
alarm systems fly off the shelves all
these things
stacked together as a way to project to
the outside world i'm not going to be an
easy target that's the message harris
wants to send and she says her neighbors
are on board a lot of people are
watching out for each other orco mana
live local now